thank you so much and uh
yeah i'm a man but i'm not amanda amanda
is at the back there and uh i just want
to say thank you amanda for giving me
the opportunity to speak here um we we
discussed the content and uh
turned out that a lot of what we wanted
to talk about is stuff i've been working
on hence
hence here i am also i want to say i
read a study
recently that said
that parole officers or parole was far
less likely to be given just before
lunch if your parole came up
just say at nine o'clock in the morning
but the judge would be far more likely
to to let you off than at 11 30. so when
you're looking at me and judging me
bear in mind that part of what you're
thinking is affected by the fact that
you need some food okay so
okay so data integration and error big
data from the 1930s to now so yeah there
was big data in the 1930s not many
people know that um but
but what we learned from big datum in
the 1930s or what our ancestors learned
is still relevant now i'll talk about
television measurement one of the
fundamental things that nielsen does and
return path data that's now available
from set-top boxes that
can help us
in that and then talk about some
questions around understanding error on
data integration
and so
on so
big data 1930s style i've
presented this slide a few times and i
generally offer a bottle of champagne
for anybody who can name the person on
this slide but i'm not going to do that
now because i know but amanda knows who
it is and
but does anybody know who this person is
okay this man is alf landon and he was
predicted by the literary digest to be
the next president of the united states
in the 1936 election
a military digest based that on big data
they had returns from millions of their
readers
uh saying who who the readers were going
to vote for they'd done the same thing
in 1932 and they got it right and they
went bigger and better in 1936
and confidently predicted that alf
landon
would be the 1936 president
now i don't know if you've checked but
he wasn't um
some fdr um
ended up being the president the
literary digest
um published
this cover is our face red and it
definitely was and they actually went
out of business because they had such a
loss of confidence from advertisers
because they really messed up
and that was based on millions and
millions of data points how could they
possibly have got it wrong the simple
answer of course is that literary digest
readers were pretty upmarket if you
could afford a literary digest you were
more likely to be better off and you're
more likely to vote republican than
democrats it was a simple case of bias
meanwhile
dr gallup um
and you can see dr gallup there on the
left and art nielsen on the right dr
gallup predicted with 50 000 interviews
based on a scientifically representative
sample that fdr would win
and that was a really seismic event um
because it really gave underpinning to
the market research industry the media
research industry that
but i've worked in for 25 years and now
it was a really really big industry but
it's all based on that foundation but if
you want to do research you've got to do
it in a scientific way you can't just
get any old data and think that it's
meaningful
so early days of research there was a
company called mass observation in the
united kingdom and what they did was
they went out and they just spoke to
people in pubs which probably quite a
fun job to do but not particularly
scientific i think they were set up by
a filmmaker
an anthropologist
and a poet
and that's the sort of research they
were doing and it gives you a very
interesting insight into britain in the
1930s but it doesn't give you anything
in terms of hard statistics so it was
really about 1936 election and the
advent of companies like gallup and
nielsen putting some sort of scientific
basis into
measurement that
was the foundation of where we are now
in in research
and then since the 1950s things have got
a little bit more sophisticated you
don't just do a sample and take it at
face value you look at possible biases
and you weight it probability models
have been brought into the equation to
help with understanding consumer trends
and so on a lot of imputation techniques
data fusion time series analyses and so
on and then really in the last few years
hybridization as we've been calling it
where you take samples that are
representative of the population and
then big data that may be a census of a
particular area of the population put
those two things together
so nielsen was founded in 1923 in 1950
introduced tv audience measurement we've
been measuring consumer products and
radio prior to that um nielsen ratings
are the currency for us tv advertising
about 65 to 70 billion dollars worth of
advertising on television based on what
our panels say our measurement panels
that
give the tv audiences so it's really
fundamentally important that that
research is is valid and accurate
so how do we do currently we use people
meters
an electronic measurement where every
television set in the household and
cable boxes and dvrs attached to
the
televisions are all measured using
nielsen meters and we ask people to
register their viewing when they're when
they're watching the tv and we generate
probability samples to do that a
television panel in the united states is
about 20 000 households approximately 60
000 individuals and visitors in the home
as well also being measured
so that's how we currently do it
because what's happening with tv uh is
more fragmentation of viewer choices
this is a dish latino channel guide um
so that's just on one platform for for
hispanics
these are
the channels that are available
and you can imagine there's lots of
different platforms a lot of different
cable operators a lot of viewing on
other devices now on mobiles
tablets and and so on
and increasing population diversity so
everything's getting more complicated
the
positive side of this so is that more
data are becoming available because as
people watch on devices information
comes back from those devices that
includes set-top boxes on on cable boxes
and also
mobile devices and pcs and so on
so where are we going with our research
the statistical tools are changing we
had really since the 1930s a very sort
of simple
statistical model to measure the
population you sample it you measure it
and then you project it
and that's pretty easy to understand
but now we're getting more complicated
we still need that
but we also are now integrating uh other
data sets with panels
uh using data fusion methods
probability modeling calibration and so
on so it is getting more complicated
but at the end of the day we still need
to be mindful of getting it right
and not making a sort of literary digest
problem
so set top box data what what can that
give us well it gives us large what you
might call convenient samples but
actually in a way convenience samples
probably not quite the terminology for
it to be fair it's more you get what you
get and you you probably know what it
represents it may represent a particular
cable
provider's
set of boxes in a particular market so
you do have a definition where sometimes
with convenience samples you don't you
just kind of get whoever you can and you
don't really have any sort of
fundamental design understanding
but what we're looking at with set-top
box data is potentially in a market
where we may have a panel of say a
thousand homes
there could be millions of boxes
providing information and and that
clearly gives us a level and scale of
data that can give us much more stable
results
however if we're in a position where a
market could be say new york where
you've got
several million households and if you've
only got one million of those giving you
set-top box data that one million may
not be representative of all the
households and so
on its own it's not going to be enough
so we look at combining the set-top box
data with panels
to give us stable but also unbiased
research
and here are the gaps and biases that
exist with set-top box data but the data
quality is an issue but we need to be
aware of i've got a slide coming up
about that the coverage as i've just
mentioned you may have a lot of boxes
that represent one particular part of
the market one particular set of
customers but but not everybody
sometimes the data may not be as timely
as we'd like it our clients are used to
getting overnight results for for tv
ratings
um and but the samples may for set top
bar samples may not therefore be fully
representative
first sort of modeling problem we face
is tv set activity you may know that the
set-top box is tuned to a particular
channel but that doesn't mean to say
that anybody is watching it
if you checked out the set top box data
from my house it would appear that i
watched comedy central from 11 o'clock
at night during the week all the way
through the night
i don't generally colbert report and
then i'll turn it off
but i don't turn the box off i turn the
tv off so we need to address that
household characteristics we may know
what the boxes are doing but we don't
necessarily know what the household is
we can get some good insights from from
tuning events
so there's heavy hispanic
channel viewing or heavy kids viewing it
gives you an idea about the demographic
composition but typically that data is
not available directly
and it is tuning information is what the
boxes are doing it isn't what people are
doing and at the end of the day
advertisers are interested in reaching
people as our program makers so we need
to model for persons viewing as well
including people who may visit the home
not just people who live in the home
and then there's other viewing activity
on other sets that may not have returned
path capability with set-top box data
unavailable and then all these other
devices that people are increasingly
using plus of course all those homes
that
are not covered by set-top box data
because maybe the data isn't available
or maybe that just for digital return
path capability isn't there
it's a lot of challenges now the concept
of total survey error is one that we
always have to be mindful of i think
when we're looking at integrating these
data because we've got
with set top box for potential for much
reduced standard error because we've got
much larger samples and that's really
the benefit but because of all the
issues i've mentioned we also have that
the problem of bias
with our people meter samples it's the
other way around we have potentially
large standard error because the samples
are not as big as we would like them to
be because of economic factors
but the bias is acknowledged to be very
low because we've got a complete
measurement so putting those two things
together should give us the best of both
worlds but this concept of total survey
era is i think a fundamental one for us
to determine whether we're improving the
measurement
so some examples of set-top box data
quality on the left what we've got is
you can see those little spikes and
those are spikes about two percent of
the population changing channels at
program junctions and that's
fairly sort of standard what we'd expect
to see based on what we know about tv
viewing so that's fine but on the right
you can see a big spike there at night
and it wasn't an earthquake it wasn't
like the data we just saw before this is
a machine reboot activity where the the
cable provider is downloading
information um
and it looks like something's happening
on the set-top box in terms of somebody
viewing it changing channel and so on
but of course
nothing like that is happening but
it's just a machine generated activity
so just an example of the sorts of
things we we have to address
so at the end of the day and you know as
i was saying about total survey era are
we improving measurement well
we have to be very transparent and we
have to validate each step and overall
and we have to have some sort of
statistical rigor and what we're seeing
here is a comparison of
overall ratings for women 18 plus for
monday to friday in november 2010
and pretty stable when we're comparing
our people meter the blue line with our
hybridized measurement but you can see
there is a bit of a gap there but i've
highlighted
and what we found with that is that it
was not statistically significant it was
close to being but it wasn't quite
statistically significant but what we're
doing with this is we're assessing for
each pair of data points whether we do
have statistical significance and then
looking about overall distribution to
see whether what we've got with our
hybrid measurement appears to
be representative of the population
and again the total survey era concept
here for females 18 plus we've got a
reduction in our total survey era as we
move to hybrid of 19
for females 18 to 34
38 and this is where we you see more
gains with the smaller demographics
because the sample sizes are smaller
there
so clearly
there's benefit here to doing this and
we've demonstrated it through a sort of
statistical process
so that's it on set top box i now want
to
talk about broader issues of integration
errors
and various things to to discuss input
error matching error and so on and i'll
get straight onto them so input error
garbage in garbage out not much you can
do about that um if the data isn't there
or if it's wrong or it doesn't quite
give you what you want then data
integration doesn't normally solve that
problem
other than you can sometimes get
improvements through integration
weighting effects an example may be that
you have a data set that is not very
good in terms of representing
young adults
because it's difficult to recruit to a
survey for example
so when you look at your overall
measurement of say 18 plus individuals
that affects the results now clearly you
can solve that through a weighting
technique just on its own but you can
also solve that almost immediately
through integration if you're then
fusing that data set onto a
representative sample and this is
something we see quite a lot with our
data fusion business where we're taking
our television panel data and we are
fusing information onto it our
television panel is a very good solid
representative sample of the population
in the u.s and by fusing data onto it
we're changing that fuse data and making
it more representative
now clearly there's only so far you can
go with that if you've got a really
really bad sample and you don't have if
you have a tiny percentage of say young
hispanics and you're interested in young
hispanics you're not going to solve
problems just through that sort of
waiting but
you know
in most cases you find you're in a
reasonably good position to um to
mitigate errors i think it's an
important point because i think a lot of
people say well
um if you know the data is what it is
and it doesn't get any better through
integration well it can do because it
can
you can approach it in a slightly more
rigorous
fashion now i'm not talking about
matching error for address matching
because this is increasingly an area
that
we're getting involved with and
it just seems a whole industry the whole
media industry and related advertisers
are getting involved with taking very
large databases maybe customer
relationship databases and then matching
as much as they can on a name and
address level and we've done quite a lot
of that
in various parts of our business around
advertising effectiveness
and
what we find is that from a marketing
perspective this works really well
because you just go to a client say
we've got single source data but it
isn't really single source data it's
address match data and you don't always
get a perfect match and i like to think
about sort of the good the bad and the
ugly good obviously is when you get a
correct match the bad is well you didn't
get a match tool but the ugly can be
when you get an incorrect match when you
think you know something about a home or
an individual but actually you don't
because you've incorrectly matched
excuse me and what you get there though
is a trade-off between match rates and
error rates because it's also not
necessarily a simple equation of this is
the exact address and the exact name
there's maybe some
slight difference then you have to make
a decision whether it's sort of close
enough is it a sort of 90 match and will
you accept that in doing that you're
going to get more matches but you
introduce the possibility of incorrect
matches
one thing i would say though is that you
if you go into multiple database
integrations
i don't think that the the error rate so
you say you had a 90 match rate on one
match and you get another 90 on another
it doesn't necessarily mean to say that
you you've
you've got a sort of 80 match overall
what you may find is you've actually
missed 10 of the population who aren't
covered on either of those databases so
you just have to be sort of conscious of
what you've got and
understand the databases and their
limitations it's difficult to to be very
sort of
you know to definitely say that there is
a multiplicative effect
so that's matching error on
names and addresses
a lot of what we're doing though is more
statistical imputation where we're
matching on a set of common
characteristics
that maybe say demographic or media
based
or purchase based
information
and in doing that then you can
introduce model bias leading to what
some people call attenuation others call
regression to the mean
um but when you're looking at any
individual data point that bias that the
model has can be undetectable just
because you've got sampling error and so
there's a level of noise around that and
this
chart sort of gives an example of that
what we've got here
is a thousand product category users
analyzed in terms of their total hours
of weekly television viewing and i've
sorted it
by
the truth the actual data
and then we've done a fusion test to see
how good the fusion is at predicting uh
those hours of viewing
so the pink line is the actual
data going from the lowest product uh
use of about 20 hours per week to the
highest one right about 35 hours a week
and then you can see the blue fused data
and it's bouncing up and down and that's
because we've got samples and we know
we're not going to get it exactly right
what we're trying to do is estimate what
the population does
and there's clearly some sampling air
around that but what this shows is that
fusion works pretty well it does track
the the pink line pretty well if we put
a best fit through which is the yellow
line you can see that
it's pretty good all the way through
apart from right at the left hand side
and right at the right hand side and
that could be some evidence of
regression to the mean there where
the
the lightest viewing is not quite as
light in in the fuse data and the
heaviest viewing is not quite as heavy
so you've got a little bit of
attenuation going on there
but as i say any look at any single any
one of those thousand points and you
wouldn't necessarily conclude that that
it was biased but it could just be by
chance variation
so how do we get around that how do we
estimate bias well what we do is for
each of those pairs of points we
calculate um a z-test and compare the
real and natural and then we look at the
distribution of z-scores convert those
two to probabilities of um other
currents and then compare them with
actual and what we've got here on the on
that pink straight line is the fact that
we would expect
that one
observation to be um difference at the
one in a thousand level and two of the
two in a thousand level and so on
because we've got a thousand
observations so we get a straight line
but what we've actually got is a
slightly um
broader
spread which is the s shape and that gap
that gap between the s shape and the
straight line that we can assume to be
the
bias that we've introduced into the
uh into the measurement so that's
typically how we do as i say it doesn't
tell you for any individual point but
you've got it wrong but it does give you
some overall feeling of the the error
that you've introduced
now when it comes to integrating
multiple data sets using statistical
techniques fusion imputation and so on
there are various ways that you can
approach it i've got two ways here the
hub and spoke approach and in a sort of
sequential approach and what we've got
here based on a single source data set
we have of our people meter television
data internet data and credit card
purchase data
is first of all on the left we're fusing
the the web use onto the tv panel and
then we're fusing the the buy purchase
data from credit card data separately
onto whereas on the right
we do the same thing for internet first
of all we just fuse the internet data
but then when we're doing the fusion of
the buy data we're also taking into
account internet usage that we have on
our buy data set
and using that so we're fusing both to
the tv and the internet data
simultaneously
when we do that in this test the
accuracy clearly improves and the
correlation between um internet usage
and
and purchase data improves from 0.4 to
point five and our overall correlation
between tv
um and internet um
and and buy goes up from point four four
to point six seven we're making best use
of the data here because we are taking
into account all the information that
we've got from the internet data
when we're we're fusing the buy data and
you can see that it's uh improving it
this is early days of this test we're
just working through this there's a lot
more we need to do but i think these are
indicative of the sorts of things that
you would expect to see that you really
want to try and use all the data that's
available to you when you're doing
fusion
fusions like this and and you do get
improvements
so
if the hub data in this case the
television data had all the relevant
linking information then um then it
wouldn't make any difference but in this
case because we're adding in the
internet data and then subsequently
using it in the sequential fusion we get
a better result
the problem you find with this though is
that it kind of works well for three
data sets but moment you start to move
beyond that then you need to be very
careful things turn into a bit of a like
mess because there are so many
intracorrelations that you need to be
concerned about and so
care needs to be taken i think when when
you're when you're doing something like
that
okay um just about running out of time
validity levels individual versus
aggregated um i won't dwell on this
because of time considerations too much
but a very important consideration here
is individual level uh predictability
versus aggregate level and a lot of what
we're doing works at the aggregate level
but
it doesn't work particularly well at the
individual level in in terms of a
perfect prediction of whether somebody
does or does not use a particular brand
of shampoo but what you can do is
predict
uh viewing levels of
that particular brands
users so that's the sort of difference
that said individual prediction even if
it's not
perfect for all uses it can still give
you improvements so
we do work with precision marketing
where we're getting 40 improvement on
random when predicting product users
based on cookie prediction so what does
that mean it means when an online
appetizer advertises they're reaching
say 14
of that product you of those product
users or 14 percent of the cookies
they're targeting um give you those
product users whereas they would have
had 10 if they hadn't done it so it's
worthwhile doing that and that can
lead them to
to win in bids for programmatic buying
by i say bidding 30 percent higher as an
arbitrage there where they're they're
getting 40 gain for 30 extra cost
okay so
in conclusion there does seem to be data
everywhere at the moment that's a great
problem to have
the data quality and relevance is
essential now as it was back in the
1930s it has its statistical integrity
and obviously you can get insights from
all this stuff but you can also get
error and
that's you know clearly something we all
have to be conscious of and
remember ralph landon
okay that's it thanks very much